flamboyant controversial and self-made
Muhammad al-fad was often on the front
pages
from business Acquisitions to taking on
the British establishment to conspiracy
allegations about the deaths of his son
Dodie and Princess Diana
born in Egypt alfad started selling
fizzy drinks on the streets of
Alexandria before beginning his wise to
become a billionaire and owning the Ritz
hotel in Paris he moved to Britain in
the 1970s building a business Empire in
real estate shipping and construction he
owned London landmarks including herod's
department store Fulham Football Club
which he helped win promotion to the
Premier League
but despite his influence and success
Alfred felt slighted by the British
establishment each voice failed to
secure citizenship
the cash for question Scandal That Shook
British politics in the 1990s followed
Val fad said he paid politicians to ask
questions in Parliament
but everything changed in 1997 when a
car crashed in Paris killed his son
Dodie and Princess Diana
he fought a long campaign insisting the
death of the Princess of Wales was
murdered
in 2008 he gave evidence at their
inquest alleging that the couple were
murdered by the British secret service
on the orders of Prince Philip what
happened to my son
and to Princess Diana is absolute clear
horrendous murder committed by the
British royal family they still don't
accept
my son an Egyptian a Muslim can be the
stepfather of the Future King
the conspiracy allegation was dismissed
by the coroner and rejected by the
inquest jury
two years later alfad sold habits to an
investment arm of qatar's sovereign
wealth fund and in 2013 Fulham FC was
sold to a U.S businessman
the club has paid tribute to him
alfad is survived by his second wife
Finnish model Haydee Wharton and their
four children
his death on Wednesday was the day
before the 26th anniversary of the crash
in Paris the tragedy he said he could
never recover from
foreign
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera